monfils qui va plus du tout les millions
même pas moi d'ailleurs c'est un drame
il était au fait de l'émission il était
planté devant donc il y avait un vrai
pour les autres l'audience a été plutôt
bonne
oui bah oui c'est un vrai carton 830
1838 et 138 téléspectateurs leader sur
la tnt ça je me suis un petit peu la
même réflexion de vous sauf que ils ont
des millions et des millions d'abonnés à
l'horizon dans très exactement 5
millions qu'a vraiment suivi pour une
fois la télévision donc celle là où 7 et
la force pour ce programme là alors y
ait beaucoup de potes hâtive de
l'adaptation est au format de youtube
eux ça marchait pas très bien
cela fonctionne pourquoi votre avis
parce qu'ils ont eu carte blanche à et
c'est le seul ingrédient que leur a
permis finalement de faire cette
émission d'hier vous prenez les codes du
web et vous les intégrer à la télévision
objectifs des chaînes également rajeunir
le public et ça fonctionne mais
généralement les jeunes aujourd'hui les
15 24 ans ils consomment la télévision
une heure 43 contre 3 heures 30 pour
l'ensemble du public
et là on voit que le public jeune suite
et revoyant la télévision c'était une
bonne chose
dimitri vous vous suivez sur les
méchants web vous êtes dans la série je
les suis sûr voilà eh ben je trouvais ça
bien
je me suis dit que ça pouvait être
intéressant si tu aimes c'est leur
offrir la possibilité de développer les
formats qui font déjà sur youtube
et c'est là qu'il fallait à mon avis
passe pas se perdre j'ai regardé
l'émission le replay hier hier soir j'ai
trouvé ça plutôt cool ça va il ya pas
l'effet de curiosité aussi soumet la
première oui mais avec très vite entre
l'âge et la pression moi j'ai vu un peu
les missions qu'ils ont fait une
émission de télé et non pas une mission
qu'ils ont amené de télévision mois on
n'a plus jamais les audiences aussi
qu'ils ont sur internet sur youtube il
ya quinze jours ils ont fait une vidéo i
love you 3,5 millions de vues sur leurs
vidéos
voilà la télévision et forcément elle
essaye d'exploiter un peu le filon de
ses bonnes audiences mais est ce que sur
le long terme ça peut durer assure juste
on va quand même préciser que quand même
la télévision c'est un instant t alors
que sur youtube fut la leur lors des
crises la journée etc
donc voilà c'est fait merci beaucoup et
magnéto qui nous ont amusé et ça c'est
typiquement un produit de télévision ont
fait des fausses pubs
regardez comment est ce qu ils font une
pub du rer c'est très drôle visiter les
plus beaux endroits de la capitale
à la collection erreur belle collection
fauteuil arraché seul col en reste de
tacos presse gratuits dans un état
douteux et même le fameux cool il urine
sèche de sdf
même les odeurs sont retranscrites à la
perfection cette bonne piste
le numéro un le wagon de la ligne b de
fontenay-sous-bois son spray humidité
dans de pointe et son fascicule sur les
plus beaux incident voyageur pourra no
99 seulement chez votre marchand de
journaux
simplement aujourd'hui le web c'est un
incubateur de talents quand arrive à
générer justement autant millions de
personnes qui te suivent c'est que tu es
obligé de réussir allez allez allez
allez fidéliser sur un écran en télé
parce que les gens aiment te regarder
donc ça va marcher obligatoire et pas du
tout je cours pour ces gens là à la base
on les connaît pas s'ils sont là
aujourd'hui
et si tmc a misé sur eux c'est parce
qu'ils ont récolté 3 millions 4 millions
sur la parodie ils sont un peu dans la
même mouvance que le pâle macho qui a
été mis en avant sur celui-ci et qui a
ensuite basculé sur tf1 mais lorsque
cyprien et norman fondé série pour tf1
en matière de fiction là ça ne prend pas
donc peut-être que la parodie c'est à
dire une autre phénomène quand même
c'est sur tmc il se trahissent pas à tmc
ce n'est pas une chaîne grand public
donc ce qu'on vient voir c'est le
produit qu'ils représentent
on vient pas voir tmc quand vous êtes
sur tf1 c'est le cas du prime la semaine
dernière de malik qui s'est planté là en
prime sur tf1
là ce moment là où vous vous trahissez
un petit peu donc sur les youtuber tant
qu'ils sont sur tmc ou sur des chaînes à
un petit peu plus confidentiels il n'y a
pas de problème on vient voir le produit
on n'est pas à parasiter par la main à
l'équipe aurait d'ailleurs le tweet
était assignée figée alors que ça fait 1
franchement c'est impossible que 800
milles sur tmc c'est plutôt bien mais
les gens sur twitter sur les réseaux
étaient pas été pas emballé 1,3 à eelv
globalement voilà que c'était pas tout
fait pas terrible un peu gênant même
donc comme quoi ya pas de corrélation
entre ce qui se passe sur les réseaux
dans un sens exact dans l'autre
exactement